okay no hi my name is Chris hell beep no
no you know your life is different now
so this video is exactly what the title
says I'm not going to be dramatic or
emotional about any of this but you
might take a quick break from making
some YouTube videos I need some space
I've been feeling very anxious about
making content and a little sad and a
little psychic overwhelmingly nervous
and fearful I'm not in a good way I used
to think about like fear being a good
sensation follow it because it means you
care about something and ultimately lead
you to some discovery or some
exploration that you didn't account for
and right now fears kind of turning into
this negative emotion for me right now
and I realized that I have been getting
just overwhelmingly consumed with trying
to make good content and good is such a
subjective thing description feeling and
so I think I need to like give myself
full permission to take a break
something I guess we call self-care it's
been the big trend lately taking care of
yourself and I haven't jumped on board
that bandwagon yet I've just fit on like
a razor scooter trying to catch up to it
and so I think I'm officially going to
take a break from making videos for a
little bit just a couple weeks I don't
know exactly how long however this isn't
really a big announcement because I will
be publishing every Monday my podcast
not too deep the videos there on this
channel and on iTunes and SoundCloud
everything and on Wednesdays Marinette
are going to be starting our new podcast
this might get weird so that'll be
available everywhere that you listen to
podcasts oh and I'm still me on social
media I just want to take a second from
making youtube videos here if that's
okay with you guys I'm also you know
this is weird timing to be like I'm
gonna go before I do I'm gonna launch
some merch too so get ready for that
it's a confusing way of being like I
want to give you something I'm gonna be
real absent so all your mummy and daddy
issues are gonna come flaring to the
surface yeah that's all I wanted to say
to you guys and I always avoid doing
anything like this in video because it
seems much like it has much more
gravitas than it does right now I just
did some space for my brain yeah I think
that's it and I might not even edit this
video I might just let this live like
this
also these tiny dark hairs in the back
get back
what symbolism that the tiny darkness is
creeping up to my neck get out of here I
don't know I'll see you guys soon follow
my social media and you'll find out or
I'll just update you there unlike what's
going on but I'm excited for it not too
deep and for this might get weird the
podcast so those will still be there
just give me a little bit of space